l'amour c'est l'essence de la vie
c'est puissant magique et merveilleux
jusqu'au moment où tout s'arrête
super as quoi ok témoin ce qui va post
qui manque c'est la personne que j'ai
rencontrée il ya trois ans ce gala était
romantique romantique tu puisses sous
mon nez je m'hydrate tu devrais contents
pour moi je suis végétarienne au mais je
mange du poisson et le pepperoni sur la
pizza
parce que ça compte pas
[Musique]
c'est monsieur winton avocat n'a les
avocats
non seulement mon frère c'est quand tu
seras morte j'ai pas dit ça je t'ai
entendu je le pensais pas c'est trop dur
ça l'est pas forcément je veux juste
être heureusement on ne dit pas se
laisser glisser amoureux ont dû tomber
amoureux parce que oui c'est douloureux
mais tu ne seras jamais si tu te jettes
pâti de falaise
je pensais que les mariages arrangés
c'était scandaleux mais je commence à me
dire que c'est peut-être la moins pire
des solutions
je veux dire regarde tes parents tout
était arrangé et ils sont super heureux
mes parents se sont rencontrés en fac de
médecine
ouais ouais
tu m'aimes et alors et alors tu vas le
laisser partir sans réagir
arrête de tenir comme ça trouve un truc
plus simple peut-être que molly moore
n'est trop différents genres moi je vois
le verre d'eau à moitié plein ll voile
ou empoisonné
écoute tu t'imagines pas toute la
pression que j'ai sur les épaules pour
toi c'est facile mais je peux pas avoir
un bébé quand je serais tellement dieu
que j'arriverai même pas le titre est le
plus heureux des hommes si tu avais une
excuse pour pas le porter ouais
[Musique]
i